to ensure Minnesota and all those Hells
Angels are there in the front row that's
why they were I was like I just got done
shooting us sons of anarchy what's
happening fellas is there he said yeah
they laughed that's pretty cool big boys
yeah big boys outlaws yeah right I told
you they're like God's a man if you want
to give them the strip club the fellas
gonna feed the birds
yeah no I'm all set I'm feeding the
birds
well I Birds admit they're [ __ ] well I
remember a friend who said our friend
goes I don't I said what's it like to be
around the Hells Angels and he goes
grizzly bears that's all just know
you're with grizzly bears I go what do
you mean guys well just yeah I you know
you can go to their chapter they might
be really cool to you but just remember
you're not a [ __ ] grizzly bear you
can be around grizzly bears you can
study them the minute you forget you're
a grizzly bear you're getting eaten and
it's the same thing you might be good
cool the guy in that chapter but a dude
comes from another chapter he doesn't
know you didn't give a [ __ ] about you so
you just got to mind your P's and Q's
and not be too familiar just not for me
in that life now you know stressed out
I'd be around that [ __ ] cuz you be
afraid somebody try to challenge you all
right they all of it though toxic them
mask unit that testosterone the killing
the drugs the bike bunnies alleged that
I like allegedly over a club where a
club allegedly your organization stop
throwing around I don't like the way
you're talking about I don't like the
way you're [ __ ] I just want to say on
record don't like the way you're talking
about certain people and those five
counts and it's not for me but you know
you bit of a snitch this might be
snitchy Monday this is snitchy Monday
let me know let me know you're wearing a
[ __ ] adorable pink you got you got a
gold chain and you just running your
mouth I'll tell you what you're a tough
guy you're big tough guy you're not
getting into any group no you're just
too much of a loose lips not for me got
that flappy tongue huh chatter yeah
[ __ ] canary all all [ __ ] squeal
canary can sing with me away for 20 G of
a canary can fly that's how you get
thrown out a window yeah that life is it
here's my thing to with the Hells Angels
you know let's say they're not do
anything but wait the Hells Angels are
suing you
that guy in the Sox hat click on that
young jeezy there suitum agrees to pay
off Hell's Angel motorcycle club yeah no
[ __ ] for what would you have my friend
with merch they tell you this story what
why is he doing that
look oh he made that oh you cannot do
the hawser no you definitely can't do
that
Dietary my friend who did who did a like
a parody of the Hells Angel thing and
they got you know because they are a
business organization a cell plugs of
merchants and they sell tons of merch
what yeah yeah but they're in there logo
and stuff like you can't [ __ ] with your
load kit cannot but the worse than
Disney I cannot [ __ ] now you're not
wearing there my friend made uh made a
shirt made shirt very similar for the
jacket had the same people can't do that
well they got a letter cuz they have
lawyers in the business there's just a
really nice to you at first well they're
just a business so they're just trying
to make offer they're gonna talk to you
they're no different than firing the kid
they've selling merch that's all someone
took this [ __ ] they get a note he
ignores it he ignored it ignored it was
a guy not that big a deal huh huh dick
month later walking down the street with
his buddies no sure
well they found them yeah stop selling
the shirts that's all please stop
selling the sure if the Hells Angels
take the time to get on their
motorcycles oh why can't they have more
why would this friend walking down son
psycho did you get the letter ah
that's all you've already you've already
did you get the letter already forced
them to spend physical energy on you
that's already a no-no can you imagine
yeah so thank them thank them for not
thank them for taking the time and give
them your offer to buy them maybe a
couple of drinks as a courtesy offer to
get your girl and offer the fill their
baby dress them with some gasoline and
have their bikes polished maybe even do
it yourself
maybe pull out a funny motorcycle shirt
maybe motivate the boys you could do
that but I don't know if they're into
that maybe pull your t-shirt off and say
can I can it can I at least polish your
fuel tank sir
[ __ ] are you doing what are you doing
got a letter email was like another B
hey right okkkk fellas what are we doing
here it's like when my son says
something like I used a word that's a
little too like he's like [ __ ] this at a
time like whoa what my son goes
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and I want to whoa right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]